so we know that a blood-borne expansion
is coming at some point and that's very
exciting news for people like me who
love blood-borne and we've been talking
in the office about what we want from a
blood-borne expansion and I'm more
interested in the story side of things
and I think that what I want from a
blood-borne expansion is is kind of how
from software dealt with Dark Souls 2
expansions which is to say they really
focused on setting and some new you know
some new mechanics of course what I'm
really interested in is sort of the
background of how we got to this place
in blood-borne in the first place I mean
it's the story of you know an ancient
civilization and the old ones and
basically how we you know how we try to
build on what we learned from that
civilization and I'm really interested
in the old ones I'm really interested in
this idea of a race that came from the
heavens or from the celestial sphere and
you know I'm curious like I'd love to
see from software just go all out and
take us to the whole world of these
people for example of the old ones
I would love us to see you know an
exploration of that ancient race itself
the Sumerians as they're known I'd love
to go back and be able to explore some
of what you know this area was like the
area where yharnam and old yharnam were
built and so on I love to go back in
time and see what it was like then for
the thumb Aryans and how they interacted
with the old ones okay so I think what I
want from blood-borne is for a reason to
kind of go back through multiple times
what I really liked about Dark Souls 2
and particular scholar scholar of the
first sin is the fact that it remixed a
lot of what we were familiar with say if
you played Dark Souls water to a bunch
of times you were kind of encouraged to
buy the re-release because everything
all the enemies were placed differently
and it really subverted your intricate
knowledge of the game so I'd really love
to go back into a blood-borne and a new
game plus three or new game plus four
and just have like the experience of
being grabbed by the bag enemy and taken
to the prison in a different location as
opposed to the same one and when I guess
kind of playing into that and subway
spectators I'd love it if they place
greater emphasis on having what what
high level of insight can do to the game
and there were certain enemies that kind
of access new moves and different
behavior patterns when insight was
really high I love it if you could go
into an expansion and have kind of like
almost remixed version of the game
through insight so the thing I really
want out of a blood-borne expansion is
more weapons I know music he said you
want to keep the weapons are small so we
could you know learn the intricacies of
everything but I feel like I usually
play skill weapons in the de Soul series
and I started off with the cave that you
know there wasn't enough there that you
know I wanted a really good s skill
scaling women so I want like fists I
love fist weapons and Dark Souls because
it's a stupidest thing you you can ever
think of like going up against a massive
you know boss with just your little two
hands so I would definitely want
something like that I didn't actually
get into chalice dungeons till the end
of blood war but I found them to be
pretty fun but they got super repetitive
and just like the format and stuff like
that so I'm really hoping that with the
expansion if they do still have
challenged unguent or if they introduced
a new chalice dungeon that it's
different because it was really cool to
see you know monsters that you got to
fight that you didn't fight in the
normal game and just seeing that and
maybe just having a different kind of
like map layout would make that a lot
more fun so what I want to see from a
blood-borne expansion is something that
brings a bit more Dark Souls back into
blood-borne and what I mean by that is a
greater variety of combat styles and
it's kind of interesting because it
looks like Dark Souls 3 you might be
coming out as well so it might not be
something they're thinking of but I mean
stuff like more ranged combat more magic
options more stuff that's not just
straight-up close combat melee and I
know that that's what blood-borne did so
well so it might not be you know even
appropriate for the game but it did get
quite repetitive almost towards the end
and that's partially because I went for
a skill build and there were really only
like two or three skill based weapons in
the game you got the
threaded cane and the blades of mercy so
I never felt I had the chance to expand
my play style with one character in the
way that I could with Dark Souls I felt
like I was locked into this one track
for the entire game so it would be nice
to see if not entirely new combat styles
then more skill based weapons or
something that actually uses your stats
in a more interesting way than just
strength and skill
you